publican congressman Matt Gaetz
represents the state of Florida he joins
us now congressman thanks a lot for
coming on so this is no defense the
right reason Stein who's never struck me
as someone I would trust personally but
does it seem odd that both the New York
Times and Amie McCabe clearly would like
the President to fire rod Rosenstein so
what does that tell you well we're only
going to find out the truth if we're
able to get rod Rosen Stein under oath
to explain what he said in the context
there appears to be no denial that he
talked about wiretapping the president
so now we're supposed to believe the
insurance policy wasn't really an
insurance policy the secret society
didn't really exist this is just sarcasm
when you're talking about taping the
president and when they said we'll know
we'll stop him they didn't mean they'd
stop Donald Trump they meant that
America would rise to its greatest
virtues so I guess we could either
believe the lyin Department of Justice
or our lyin eyes so again I don't want
this to come off as some sort of Defense
of permanent DOJ personnel whom as I've
said many times I would not trust on the
other hand consider this so Annie McCabe
apparently is under investigation by the
US attorney in DC based on that IG
report from DOJ that said that he leaked
and lied about it so he could be
indicted if that's true and I think it
is then no one at DOJ could call Andy
McCabe a liar without invalidating the
case in other words the prosecutor can't
call the person he's charging a liar
before the case or a judge will throw it
out so maybe they can't actually deny
this for that reason well there were
other people in the room Tucker I've had
sources who've said Scott schools was in
the room and that he's the other
anonymous source cited in the New York
Times piece so let's bring Scott schools
back from his uber job let's bring rod
Rosen Stein down why not put him under
the under oath and ask them and if we
Renata for if we're afraid to do that as
a Republican Congress then you know we
are AB we're derelict and our oversight
responsibilities we got to find out if
they like how appropriate let's assume
it was a joke Tucker how appropriate is
it for the Deputy Attorney General to be
joking about wiretapping the president
while he's overseeing an investigation
of the president in front of his
colleagues and subordinates Roseanne
Barr got fired for a joke and frankly I
think rod Rosen Stein might too
interesting so I want to ask you a
speaking of the Congress's obligation
as an oversight body these documents
pertaining to the Russia investigation
particularly the FISA warrant that
allowed the Obama administration to spy
on Carter page we were promised that
they would be declassified and
apparently the permanent bureaucracy has
prevented that from happening it's
deeply frustrating to those of us who
believe in transparency and openness and
the public's right to know the details
of what his government is doing behind
its back can anything be done about this
or is it final well I think that there
were some who convinced the president
that since the Inspector General is
already looking at this content that if
the inspector general finishes it will
all come out anyway that's frustrating
for guys like us who want to turn all
the cards face up on the table but I do
have great confidence that Michael
Horowitz will get to the bottom of this
and we'll issue a fair report so we may
have to wait a little longer than we
would have liked but I don't think that
the deep States going to be able to hide
behind their inappropriate redactions
for too long so at least has one final
question if the and I think you're
absolutely right
everything in the end becomes known
nothing is hidden forever so when these
documents are finally released to the
people who own them which is to say the
American people and it turns out that
none of the things that were redacted
were actually questions of national
security but merely but covering by
federal employees well all the people
who lied about it get punished because
they should well they've never been
punished before when we had text
messages redacted just because Peter
struck was friends with a judge or Andy
McCabe bought a $60,000 conference table
there were no consequences there was no
punishment we just sort of threw our
hands in the air and lost trust and
their ability to do their own redactions
but time and again bureaucrats redact
information that's embarrassing to them
that the American people have a right to
know and that's why we've got to
continue to fight for Congress to have a
robust oversight role nicely put
congressman thanks very much for joining
us